and so three guys go to confront
Hamilton on these charges one of the
dudes was future President James Monroe
there yep Hamilton we know what you did
you know what you did check out these
checks to James Reynolds what's up and
they accuse him of embezzling funds and
Hamilton goes no no I was just eating as
lady and her husband was hitting me up
for money I didn't talk to American
money and I have all kinds of proof and
he'd like vomits information all over
them oh wow that was more than we needed
to hear and we're good thanks the info
about the affair gets somehow
miraculously printed in the paper
Hamilton is not a great dude
I know you think he's great cuz he's a
war vet he's the Treasury secretary but
you're gonna learn the truth real soon
and Hamilton gets this and he goes to
James Monroe I told you that in secret
and then James Monroe's like it wasn't
secret it wasn't me wasn't me who
published it mother I told three people
about this and you're the one who was
taking notes so I know it came from you
like fess up you so Hamilton overshare
writes the Reynolds pamphlet the whole
thing reads like a dear penthouse letter
like dear America I never thought this
would happen to me but one day this
ripped botas woman showed up at my door
saying oh my husband's beating me left
me alone and I need money and I need to
help you our man of honor can help me
Hamilton's like I could give her money
or I could hurt and either one would be
acceptable the Reynolds pamphlet is like
dick 101 and by the way he said this to
his friends being like hey I think I'm
gonna publish this and everyone was like
hey beau I don't think this is a good
idea to publish this like maybe your
wife and your seven children would not
love it if you publish this and
Hamilton's like wow like I got accused
of embezzling like I can't let that
stand
maybe the like marital infidelity trumps
that I know it doesn't in your head but
to everyone else in the world it does um
and he's like no I can't let that
stand and Hamilton goes back to James
Monroe and now
Hamilton's like well it's all out in the
open um and if you still want to settle
this because I know you're the one who
leaked it Monroe's like well I didn't
leak it but if you want to like fight
like let's do this
you